[Music]
oh maybe i just wasn't good enough
to blow your mind
you know
so give it up
the fool's
[Music]
we just keep on digging
next time
so maybe i just wasn't strong enough
make
next time
oh
diamonds in our eyes
next time
hmm
hey friends i hope that was sassy enough
for y'all out there um yeah this
actually came up because that song came
up in my apple music suggested one day
and it just made me want to move and so
it's just like yep we're going to do
that so i hope you appreciated seeing me
pull out some old choreography as well
as
just playing around with uh with some
sassy body moves there
just want to put out a huge thank you to
ultra poi for sponsoring this video and
making it possible for me to get out and
flow around town
you can grab a set of those or poi led
contact poi that i was using in this
video by heading on over to ultrapoi.com
and using the promo code drexfactor with
a zero instead of an o at checkout that
gets you a discount on your order and it
helps out the channel so everybody wins
thank you once again to ultrapoi for
sponsoring this video
and speaking of thank yous uh big thanks
to the friends of the channel thanks to
dark monk fire mecca flow fests flow
toys pyroterra light toys juggling
calling spinballs and ultra poi for
helping to make all the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these different companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that i've got down in the
description of this here video and a
special thanks for the non-business
friends of the channel that is johnny
howard les machinski and becca beckham
thank you one and all for your support
for my work and my mission
and on the last note of thanks a big
thanks is uh is is is owed to uh these
people right here these are my uh these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along the people listed down in the
description helped make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
uh thank you one and all for your
wonderful support
and if you like the content that i
create
and are not currently a supporter you
can become one by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactorpoi and signing up
you can get access to a whole host of
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out on my mission to bring
flow arts and poi spending to the wider
world and helping people connect with
their brains and their bodies so go
check that out please and thank you
also thank you for watching this video i
really really appreciate it and
i know that ultrapoi does as well um if
you'd like to check out more videos of
me getting my flow on i will include a
link to a playlist of other videos just
like this one down in the description or
up on screen if you are watching this
video on youtube make sure to get
outside and flow yourself today the
weather hopefully is as gorgeous for you
as it was for me and i will see you with
a new video next week thanks again
peace